Malnutrition may not make headlines like a famine does...
...but not having proper nutrients can be just as deadly.
You see, hunger isn't just a stomach thing.
It affects every part of the body and these effects can last for a lifetime.
For instance, a healthy brain uses 20% of the body's energy...
...and that energy comes from?
You guessed it, food.
When a child is hungry the brain is starved, the result?
Malnourished kids fall behind in school because they can't concentrate.
Skin and bones are also affected by nutrition.
Healthy skin is like armor, shielding the body from infection.
And healthy bones get bigger and stronger as a child grows.
But when a child is malnourished, their skin cracks...
...allowing infections to get in.
We need to catch hunger before it starts...
...by making sure kids aren't just getting enough food, but the right food...
...so that they have the best possible chance at a healthy, successful life.
Do World Vision's 30 Hour Famine and help build a better world for children.